FACTS INSTEAD OF RHETORIC,
SEAN.
>> Sean: ED HENRY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, MAYBE HE SHOULD
READ THE CONSTITUTION, SOMETHING
ABOUT CHECKS AND BALANCES.
THAT IS PART OF IT.
JOINING US WITH MORE REACTION,
RON DeSANTIS, TV CONTRIBUTOR,
FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT DAN
BONGINO, I AGREE WITH
GREGG JARRETT, DAVID SHOWING, GO
TO VENT ABOUT, CONGRESSMAN, I
AGREE WITH ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
THIS IS A PERJURY TRAP, IT IS
JUVENILE, THE FACT THAT YOU ASK
THE PRESIDENT WHAT WAS IN YOUR
MIND IS IN ABSURDITY, AND IT
SHOWS JUST HOW FAR THIS HAS GONE
FROM SO-CALLED COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, SEAN, VERY FEW
OF THE BULLETS INVOLVED A
CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS MOSTLY DURING THE
TRANSITION AND THEN DURING THE
PRESIDENCY.
SO YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
ROBERT MUELLER, HE IS A DOJ
EMPLOYEE, EFFECTIVELY.
HE HAS AN INFERIOR OFFICER IN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
WHAT GIVES HIM THE RIGHT TO
CONDUCT OVERSIGHT OVER BASIC
PRESIDENTIAL DECISIONS?
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH ANY
TYPE OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
WHAT WAS IN YOUR MIND WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT JEFF SESSIONS WERE
ASSIGNING OR THIS OR THAT?
HE DOES NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SUBPOENA THE PRESIDENT FOR THAT,
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT SUBMIT
TO THOSE QUESTIONS.
AND I AGREE WITH ALAN DERSHOWITZ
AND YOU, SEAN, I THINK THAT
REALLY THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO
INVESTIGATE A CRIME, THEY ARE
TRYING TO MANUFACTURE A
PROCESSED CRIME.
>> Sean: DAN BONGINO, NO GOOD
LAWYER IN THE RIGHT MIND KNOWING
WHAT WE KNOW, KNOWING THE
ABUSIVELY BIASED TEAM LIKE
WISEMAN AND COMPANY THAT WAS
APPOINTED BY MUELLER, WOULD
ANY PRESENT DENT LET HIM GO
BEFORE THE MAN AT ALL?
AND THE THREATS OF THE PRESIDENT
EARLY IN THE PROCESS BEFORE THEY
COOPERATED AND NEVER EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> DO YOU SEE THE DANGER IN
THIS?
THEY ARE NOT INVESTIGATING A
CRIME HERE.
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING
DONALD TRUMP.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE.
I WAS A FORMER FEDERAL AGENT,
YOU INVESTIGATE A CRIME AND YOU
FIND PEOPLE.
YOU DO NOT FIND PEOPLE AND THEN
GO FIND THE CRIME.
I READ THE QUESTIONS, AND SEAN,
THESE QUESTIONS ARE VERY
STRATEGIC.
NOTICE HOW THEY ARE LEFT
OPEN-ENDED.
NOW RON IS A LAWYER, HE CAN TELL
YOU THAT'S TOO.
THIS IS WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU
INTERVIEW PEOPLE AS A FEDERAL
AGENT.
OPEN-ENDED QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: NO YES OR NO
QUESTIONS.
>> EXACTLY, BINGO.
>> Sean: IF THERE IS ONE THING
THAT DEVIATES AND YOU ARE ON A
WITCH HUNT, THERE IS NO
PROSECUTORIAL DISCUSSION, THE
ONLY WAY HE GETS THAT IS
HILLARY CLINTON, THE RIGGED
INVESTIGATION.
THE HILLARY STANDARD IS NOT
GOING TO APPLY FOR DONALD TRUMP
WITH ROBERT MUELLER AND HIS
MERRY BAN OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS
AND PEOPLE THAT WITHHOLD
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE LIKE ANDREW
WEISSMANN.
NO, HE IS NOT GOING -- HE WILL
BE UNDER OATH UNDER LIKE
HILLARY, NOT A FRIEND
INTERVIEWING HIM LIKE HILLARY
HAD.
IT IS SO FLAGRANT HERE, DO WE
HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE
LAW?
DO WE HAVE TO EQUAL APPLICATION
UNDER THE LAW OR NOT IN THIS
COUNTRY?
>> JUST THE FACT THAT THESE
QUESTIONS ARE BEING GENERATED,
WAS THERE A COPIOUS NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED OF
HILLARY AND HER FBI INTERVIEW?
THAT WAS A PERFUNCTORY THING.
THEY HAVE ALREADY DECIDED NOT TO
BRING CHARGES.
COMEY WROTE THE MEMO TWO MONTHS
BEFORE THEY EVEN INTERVIEWED
HER.
SO THE LACK OF ZEALOUSNESS AND
THEN THE OVERZEALOUSNESS HERE IS
VERY, VERY STRIKING.
AND LOOK, IT SHOULD BE
CONCERNING TO ALL OF US.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
THE INVESTIGATION IS THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO NAIL
ANYTHING THEY CAN TO THE WALL
AND OF COURSE YOU AND I AND
AGAIN, WE ALL WATCH THE HILLARY
CASE WHERE THEY DID NOT GO
AFTER BLEACH BIT.
THEY DID NOT TO GO AFTER PUMA OR
ANY OF IT.
>> Sean: AND HOW DOES ROD
ROSENSTEIN, ONE PERSON THAT
SIGNS OFF ON A DOSSIER MANDATED
APPLICATION TO A IS A COURTS
WHEN THEY ARE IN LINE WITH THE
FISA JUDGES, HOW DOES HE NOT
RECUSE HIMSELF?
WHERE IS JEFF SESSIONS SAYING
THAT YOU NEVER SHOULD'VE BEEN IN
THIS?
A GET OUT!
>> SEAN, ROD ROSENSTEIN IS THE
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY IN IN
MARYLAND ON THE URANIUM ONE
PRECURSOR CASE.
THIS GUY IS SO CONFLICTED, HOW
HE HAS NOT RECUSE HIMSELF OR
REDESIGNED IS AMAZING.
>> Sean: WHEN HE SAID, OH,
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES IF THERE IS
FALSE INFORMATION ON A FISA
APPLICATION PERIOD HE SIGNED ONE
THAT WAS NOT TO VERIFIED OR
COOPERATED AND HILLARY PAID FOR
IT AND THEY NEVER TOLD THE
JUDGE.
>> HE NEEDS TO GET OFF THIS CASE
LIKE YESTERDAY.
>> Sean: FULL DISCLOSURE, I DO